[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot we
are here on lobby our weekly video game
hangout here every Wednesday at 11 a.m.
in San Francisco California Pete Brown
what do you were you looking Oh Pete
Brown reviews editor you're gonna be
talking a lot about pirate today I would
presume as long as you let me we we're
all kind of taken by surprise we
expected it might be a good game but it
turns out it's really good
yeah I didn't really know what to expect
it was an awesome surprise cool so we'll
get into that in a little bit I'm here
with Rob handler as well and I'm sure
you are gonna try to hijack the show and
talk about titanfall to the entire time
as long as you let me and I'll have to
rein that back no just kidding it's
really fun new horde co-op mode out
yesterday for the game and you played a
lot of it it's time to come back so we
get into that shortly and Callie you've
been playing a bunch of different things
and I know you're starting in another
review soon but a little bit did you
review dream daddy are we just playing
it I don't know I've been playing it I
don't have time to water because I'm
going on to this next review but I will
talk about that as long as you let me
cool so get into all that stuff we do
have a giveaway I'll announce that at
the end of the show and wow that was a
really uniform response from all three
it was really good and we're also
getting it into fortnight which I've
been playing a lot and I want to talk
about yeah cool some news first as usual
so some people found that when they
opened their email the other morning
their nest classic pre-orders from
Walmart had been cancelled no not me I
my my period was cancelled I got two of
them it was a really good night I got a
chicken dinner in pub G and then
actually during the match like a chicken
dinner I went prone in this building to
pre-order these two senesce classics no
well I know because well apparently I
was still too slow because they got
cancelled I woke up the next day I said
my card info couldn't be verified
apparently they said that to a lot of
people but Pete here apparently has both
of his still he must have beat me to the
punch
yeah so I don't there's no word on when
they'll go back up or when they'll go up
an Amazon or anything you know hopefully
sometime soon because what that comes
October 6th it's getting delivered or
something September 29th is when it
comes out okay for some reason Walmart
so they're gonna send me on the 6th
because there's
slow that's one you would have gotten in
in the mail yeah I think so yeah some
people had them cancelled some people
did not but obviously we will be on the
lookout for when they go back up on
pre-order wherever they might be and we
will let you all know hopefully I will I
there's it
I don't maybe wait Peter yes I buy one
player a player knows background which
is in early access this year and a lot
of people been playing it across five
million sold the other day I think it
was last weekend so it's still doing
really well obviously it's a game that's
been bolstered by its streaming
community and we here at GameSpot have
been enjoying a little more Jake and I
have been kind of streaming it done two
weeks now we're gonna try to keep that
going every Monday obviously it can be a
fun game to watch but more fun to play
pretty tense game Kelly you first we
talk about what I just realized my
graphics card is too old to run Poggi
really I have I have a 670 I think the
minimum 660 but it does not run what do
I recommend
so I have an hour logged in that game
have not successfully played a game yet
didn't we just got a few new pieces for
the like office use right yeah you'd
like it
yeah as I'm sure you already know if you
try playing it but what what did you
want to say the developer is has like a
no tolerance policy for [ __ ] what
yeah great
what is it the streamer mr. disrespect
you like killed killed thank you like to
free up a seat in a car yeah that wasn't
so he got temporarily banned for that
right and then on Twitter he like
jokingly threatened Brennan green or
player known with violence yeah yeah
yeah and player knows responds he did
like a like twit longer or whatever was
really mature because it was just saying
like hey this isn't a joke to me because
I literally was attacked once yeah you
don't know who you're talking to you
when you joke about assaulting someone
and you might be causing them to
remember really horrible things that
they don't remember I just thought that
was it was really even
well done and the kind of mr. disrespect
is vying for respect I think that's a
lost cause
yeah that so yeah he I think he carried
his character over into Twitter too too
much apparently um but yeah so good for
Brennan Greene
he just started I also the history of
player notes battleground is super weird
the battles the history did I say that
the history of pleasure pissed the
pissed story of player on the background
started Brennan Green was a photographer
in Brazil he started modding battle
royale for ArmA and then came a farmer -
and then that moved over to ARMA 3 and
and then like Sony picked up the idea
with King to kill and h1z1 and he was
doing some consulting for it and now
it's its own standalone thing because
dayz is its own standalone thing so I
moved on and he's doing really well
across five million tomorrow is kind of
a big issue date for a couple minor
releases doom fists will be available on
all platforms for overwatch if you want
to get into that did you see the
cosplayer the first doom fists cosmetic
to comic-con yeah I kept wondering how
heavy it was I guess I guess he doesn't
really he just saw the character art but
apparently he doesn't really know
overwatch or know much about doom fist
in terms of the game's design because
they were doing photos and they're like
alright all the offense characters come
up here and he didn't really know what
Duva said I think he's a Broadway actor
but it was a really good cosplay but
yeah anyway you could play as doom fest
tomorrow
not just on PTR a ton on platforms
tomorrow Thursday July or just tomorrow
the 26th 28th I'm really behind so there
you go you can see the cosplay right
here and there's another group saving
her nose off now that's ignored right
there who's I don't know who's CRISPR
who's like browser is this recommended
and that knows off tomorrow overcooked
comes to the switch yeah tomorrow is the
27th why am i saying yeah today's 26
overcooked the co-op game where you're
frantically running around a kitchen or
a restaurant making meals with other
people it's really fun
I played it the last time I played it
was our Extra Life marathon
was fun like co-op times I've had is
playing overcooked um it's one of those
games that like the first time I played
it I immediately wanted to play it again
I'm really excited to play it on switch
cuz I'll actually have my switch with me
everywhere I go it seems like it would
be one of those games where you actually
have people huddled around the like in
the commercial yeah yeah or I guess it
seems like one of the game or that seems
halfway feasible yeah you get on the
roof of your New York apartment building
yeah
huddle around the switch Kelly you want
to join us it's a party
bring your switch bring your Mochaccino
over here and start playing over coach
with us and then Neo DLC also came out
yesterday the Defiant honor dlc the
second DLC for neo the souls like game
if you will but a really good game I
mean to go back to it I'm hoping to get
back into it play these DLCs eventually
but came by yesterday miguel concepción
has been playing it I think Eric Taemin
I jumped in a little bit but we will
have more none of us got the chance to
play it because it's a little more
involved than like titanfall 2 DLC but
I'm gonna want to play that soonish
and we can you can go check it out the
video and just like I've written
thoughts on GameSpot I want to be good
at this game it looks so interesting it
is really fun it copies a lot of the
Dark Souls formula but I think it
changes a lot of it to the point where
it's a very neat game on its own it's
fun fighting with a maple leaf get out
of here
is that what that was yeah oh yeah you
have a you have like spirits that you
can summon any of muskets and you have
cannons apparently
yeah yeah hey was playing actually I
just recalled him dying from those that
arrow storm the other day putting him on
blast right now cool sweet Kelly dream
daddy yay like so we talked a little bit
about the weird non controversy about
dream daddy but dream daddy is actually
really really good it's really well
written it's funny there is like a mini
game where you have to brag about your
daughter in the style of a Pokemon
battle it was just like I I was actually
really emotional because I
I love my daughter she's perfect and I
want her to succeed in life it's just
it's really fun
there's even a hidden ending that people
were finding you can look up the cult
ending that is crazy cult ending wait is
it about a cult or is it just like it
has a cult following it's not a no no
there's an ending that's about I won't
spoil it if you don't want it to be
spoiled but just look that up there's
actual sprites and stuff I don't think
people have gotten it in the game but
it's you know it's reminds me a lot of
how the whole boyfriend in that it's
very tongue-in-cheek
it understands the dating sim genre and
it's kind of making fun of it you make
your own dad book profile and you can
say you can answer questions like if you
could take one thing on a desert island
what would you bring and you can be like
my trusty grill my copy of you know
whatever I'm Bible yeah not the Bible
that's not anything but it's really good
I would really recommend it if you like
dating sins it's really funny and I'm
having a lot of fun with it you say it's
like very wholesome yet also manages to
be sexy it's not wholesome I would not
say no like the idea of like your
daughter being like a thing that's
really you have a really really good
relationship with your daughter in the
game and you can get multiple it's kind
of cool you have these two parallel
stories going you have whoever whichever
dad you decide to date and then you have
the story with your daughter and there's
you can get the good ending in the bad
ending with her as well and she's you
know going through her troubles in high
school and that part yet rewrite is very
wholesome but you can there's not like
sex scenes or anything like that
but there was I I decided for my first
run-through I was gonna go for the worst
dad possible just as like nice warm up
and he picks you up from a bar
immediately
and I was like oh okay so yeah kind of
it balances those things well though you
just I got a bad dad achievement that's
not a good dad
Errol Moss and twitch said Kelly who was
best dead
Brij whoa I made up the name Chris but I
was close I got the first so part I
think Craig is the best dad he's he's
your friend from college he's oh there's
the dad brag about the dad brag about
your daughter minigame I lost by the way
his daughter is more accomplished than
my daughter
but mine's better I'm seeing a cosplay
floating around there so their daughter
I saw a fantastic cosplay of the
daughter a fantastic cosplay of the
actually one of the best dads is Matt he
works in a coffee shop and I saw
fantastic cosplay of him as well was
just a barista
he has like really pun heavy like a pun
heavy menu it'll be like oh you can
order like the ice - Tegan and Sara or
whatever and he asks you to help him
name his banana bread and I chose banana
bread Kennedy's but there was also a
great - annoyed what is it
so I saw you like creating a dad oh
they're creative dads wait hold on let
me let me backtrack
I saw you creating a dad that looked
like the guy from Iron Giant I did and
let me backtrack I saw you creating a
dad that looked very very weirdly
similar to the dad from Iron Giant it's
like they expected you to do that
yeah it's because this haircut actually
see right now is this him this is not me
but I would like to point out that
that's why we're to bed sorry I'm so
sorry the portrait and the bottom left
also changes and it's so creepy actually
really inclusive in a quiet way that I
liked like it wasn't like look at us we
included all of the check marks that we
needed to be diverse it's just like you
have the option to be a trans dad
essentially and have like the binder
body option combined you're being what a
lot of female and male trans people will
wear for like before top surgery and
stuff like that
which I thought was really cool you can
also be bi or gay you can say like your
daughter had a mother who passed away or
a father stuff like that but it gives
you the option and I like that it was
just really subtle it wasn't like
alright this is the gay dad simulator
here's all of the it's it normalizes it
it doesn't try it doesn't try to prop it
up yeah and so I played that honestly I
bought this because I was like this is
going to be a hilarious joke I can't
wait to play this but I it was actually
really heartwarming heartwarming with
the daughter stuff and really enjoyable
and I laughed a lot playing it because
the dad you build influence how other
dads treat you know you could build
there's actually options to make your
dad look like Goku you can straight-up
make Goku they don't like think you're
hotter or less hot depending it's it's
you know love is blind
that's well yeah the character creation
just put glasses on him as you said that
[Laughter]
that's an awesome shirt you should write
for this game oh cool that's not what
that dad dream daddy it's out on what
yeah cool it's only $15 so okay how long
is it you could play a lot cuz there's I
think six dad's six dads to date six or
seven it's like a lifetime worth of dads
yeah a lot of dads today it's more than
I have there's good and bad bad ending
so I got the bad ending with the [ __ ]
dead excuse me and Robert
so [ __ ] the Fox a while back asked a
question that I thought would kind of
get you going uh
the Fox on YouTube says does anyone even
play titanfall 2 anymore Oh
[Laughter]
yesterday frontier defense update
released for titanfall to explain what
it is to us and why it's one of the
bigger updates aside from what was the
new Titan new Titan was monarch yes I'm
from on earth wise it's one of the
bigger updates to titanfall 2 in the
year or so that it's been out good
question good question uh it implements
four player co-op your horde mode if you
will and it's probably one of the best
keep together it's probably one of the
best horde modes I've ever played like
it's like sometimes those can be you
know kind of slapped onto a game but
like here it's like it's really very
separate as well and we're gonna know
more about that I guess but like it's
you know it's a completely different
feature as far as like your progression
you know you have these things called
aegis ranks right where there are
specific to your Titan so the more you
play as a specific Titan you kind of
increasingly build up different types of
abilities that are really very much game
changers the kind of Opie stuff but then
most start getting into the higher
difficulties of this mode and you
realize you need them yes correct well
that's the cool thing I here's how I
think it can happen and just to give an
idea of like what one of these abilities
would be is like you there's like twelve
ranks I think so someone like scourge is
it nine from what I saw yes okay nine
it's my memory is X so one of the like
second the last ability for scorch who
has a very slow fire rate with his
thermite launcher one of the last ones
is you can fire three consecutively
without having to reload which is huge
for someone like that usually course a
lot scorch is great scorch is great and
that for me yes I know you use one the
only like aspects of the game that I
like a really big buff so people say and
I were doing this live stream yesterday
which is really fun it's it's funny to
see all these late the community is
really great and fun to to see progress
where people are calling him now pop
scorch yeah all these puns and people
just love you know their their main and
and they like to kind of have you know
very fun
there's fanfiction
oh I'm sure anyways before we talk about
cheese so yeah just rank is specific to
frontier defense right but you're all
your other progression is consistent
across PvP and this right so you can
upgrade like my ronin who's the one I've
been working on he was level like 14
when I first got into it and I ranked
him up to 17 the aegis rank does not
those like more powerful abilities and
attacks don't factor into PvP stuff but
for now they don't right there was a
hard time believing they ever will those
are pre well big your oh you're
absolutely right and I was think about
it too and I see it as just if they do
implement into PvP it would be its own
mode right yeah you would you would
definitely have to keep it separate oh
yeah it was like iron banner in destiny
or something that takes into account
those kind of imbalancing abilities it's
really fun and its really fun so yeah
you you know you have these waves
they're five waves they get increasingly
more difficult as you can imagine you
have enemy types that have the wield
mortars so you the the premise of the
horde mode is that you have a harvester
that you need to protect and if it's
destroyed then you lose and you have
three retries to survive five mode so
you have yeah these enemy types like
mortars that are like further away from
your harvester that are kind of you know
luring you out on your top yeah you have
to take them out or else they'll rain
havoc on your harvester and then so so I
had played in order to get to doctors
there's four difficulties easy regular
hard and Master I played there's an
insane I thought it's probably it's like
it's weird it's like a whole separate
difficulty I don't even know what it's
like but because you have to actually
level up your aegis rank so in order to
get to hard you have to have I think a
rank of five or ten I believe and chain
I just did for the sake of the stream we
just did regular and or just regular
mode and it was by the end of it we were
actually as it's kind of easy then I
tried hard mode and my god
was crawling by the end of it and that's
what I really really enjoyed and I and
it was really difficult and you start
seeing all these implemented aspects of
like the any enemy ties especially for
Titans like I Mikey you were talking
about so here you can see a scorch with
a nuclear or no Allegiant with a nuclear
icon over it meaning nuclear ejection so
when you destroy him he's gonna explode
and do an insane amount of damage if you
don't take out those guys prior to them
getting in the vicinity of your
harvester you're gonna lose you have to
take those guys out quickly because they
will wreck your Harvester yeah and so by
in hard mode by like the last wave it's
just an onslaught like a dozen of these
guys and it's so panic inducing and just
fun and so yeah you you're strategizing
here you know like many other hard modes
you you know in between rounds you're
buying arc traps you see their turrets
you're you know you're getting strategic
you're putting the our tracks and our
traps and lanes there's one there on the
bottom the bottom left that's nuclear
you if you rodeo a Titan when you get
off you immediately call us him to
explode yeah so that is kind of pushing
you to get out and down the lanes as
quick as possible to get out you know
take out these nuclear Titans the thing
I like about this DLC is it actually
makes me rethink house my loadouts work
so I'm definitely gonna I mean how many
loadout slots do you get higher up
levels I don't know I'm sure like my 9
and 10 slots I'll make specifically for
frontier defense because I told you I've
been working on Ronan and you said there
are some Titans that have that you could
see right here they mark the arc
electricity surrounding them and they
face torment cuz Ronan's move into close
quarters yeah so but also when I get
might when i unlock my sword core for
Ronan which is like his you know
ultimate so to speak he you know like
there's 4 Titans coming down a lane
whereas in multiplayer I'd save that for
when I can take out 1 or 2 enemies and
I'll kind of be conservative about it
because I don't want to just die in this
I'll be the only one that Lane the other
three people will be off doing their own
thing and I'll activate it kind of you
know more arbitrarily or not arbitrarily
more you know on a whim right away
because I need to defend them for that
so it then there is also like I'm anti
Titan weapons are much bigger now or not
much bigger but I use them much more
plus they revamp the weapons
them earlier so you could have to you
have the side our nation it's a Titan
which painting which one of the biggest
gripes of this update because they are
there they're always changing balancing
the one thing I see a lot of people
commenting on is that they actually
nerfed a lot of the almost all of the
pistols which is kind of a bust having
that slot now and it's like great I
don't there's no point using it so this
is always cool when you're so you you
know you have actually infinite respawns
so it's just about keeping your
harvester life so here you are like
entering on a dropship you know doing
damage from above they even added the
drones which I totally forgot we're in
the single-player drone enemy types that
they come in and waves so you just see
them coming round over a buildings and
just flocking in you just hose them down
reminds me look like this is a weird
comparison but it reminds me of like
Matrix Revolutions just those sentinels
coming at you and you're the Titan just
like those were in the first one - at
the end well just that the ending battle
they have in the yeah the desire was I
on whatever yeah anyways
Nebuchadnezzar yeah and the other the
other great that's a tough word to say
good job the other name the other cool
thing is that you have different types
of waves you know maybe you'll get again
like nuclear Titans coming in or just a
bunch of grunts they're very specific to
maps so there are five Lee five Maps
currently they'll implement the mode and
two other ones down the road and this is
the new map rise from the first game
which people love but they're they're
very specifically you were telling me
and I had played and just until
yesterday the Blackwater Canal map
mmm-hmm they which has the big canal in
the middle the enemy waves filter
through and down that one lane under the
bridge
yeah and in downtown the wedge the waves
cater to that so they're different I
guess I'm trying say is each map is very
different as far as strategy goes yeah
and this one seems much less lane base
the one I'm watching right now oh it's
got like three main lanes but they all
all maps gotta be the lack water just
very very very like three approaches
aside from the mortar guys you can go
over rooftops yeah the thing is I kept
telling you is I really want to play
with friends and have voice chat because
it's pretty key like it's really really
team work
hendrik yeah we're like you want to have
as you said loadouts to write like you
know you think you like cloak but now I
wasn't realizing which is a an ability
that I end up would never use is a wall
where it's like I just put down my a
wall and I could be that defensive
player and just use like anti-italian
was a shield for those who don't shield
but when you you output through it it
does a damage boost yeah like don't fall
so that would be a role and another role
would be like I'm gonna I'm gonna get
down early and like take out these
Titans but yeah it's very team centric
and I think it's super fun and unique
and if you know if you again drift it
off from the multiplayer because you
thought it was a little too competitive
or difficult this is like a whole new
way and yeah playing this game yeah lion
peach and the YouTube chat I was just
saying it's funny that this released the
same week as like Titan falls sorry for
tonight's soft launch to wave defense
things obviously zombie Chronicles came
out recently seems like it's not a
resurgence I don't think wave defense
kind of survival mode ever went anywhere
but it is funny we'll talk more about
fortnight later but it's funny that a
titanfall to update does wave defense
better than fortnight in my opinion oh
wow
in a few ways but that's not the best
like the fairest comparison but they are
going for part of their fortnight's
design is wave defense and I'm having
much more fun with titanfall to use wave
defense titanfall to is also a really
good example of games that are really
really supporting their communities
after launch there's overwatch you have
like Ubisoft has been doing really well
to the division they made much better
Rainbow six siege like doubled its
player base eight months after or
something yeah it's it's really great
like I again like the subreddit of the
games that I am obsessed with and look
into the sub reddits like that so red is
so cool to see like the one of
developers be the kind of spokesperson
and like post the patch notes we're also
doing QA like if when people are being
vocal about changes that they don't like
it's just a very like healthy
conversation like there's never a post
that's like are you booking you know
like to any kind of like bashing or
swearing or being like overly aggressive
for so many games you see like can get
nasty
you know they completely listen to their
fans at
time like yeah like tumble see did that
to where they released a patch because
people were like not beating that game
like 0.8 percent of people beat that
game or something like that they were
like alright we heard you guys it's too
difficult and they wrote this whole
thing out the developers and it's just
it's nice to have that open channel like
a they're listening and then they it's
more of a conversation rather than just
people yelling in to avoid writing like
it's too hard I hate this yeah I don't
have to be like players versus
developers right yeah right we both want
this game to be good yeah yes I'm
interested to see it's not the same
developer obviously but battlefront 2 is
gonna have free DLC as well so I'm
interested to see how they how EA kind
of implements that stuff as far as EA is
concerned as the publisher of both games
you know you know the deal scene you
know or updates post launch you know
they need to make money obviously and
title is really great about separating
out with cosmetics like I'm always like
happy to give that five dollars for a
skin again having all the updates be
free like it also big people want to
just pick up the game if maybe they
didn't see anything there they wanted
before it's like geez when this came out
it was one thing but it's a totally
different thing now so maybe I'll buy it
yeah you could play just frontier
defense and still right level up in the
same progression system plus they just
system totally and I responded some guy
I think on YouTube who was like is this
worth picking up and it's like some
kinda said it best was like I I'm pretty
sure he's right but the game is $20 I
think for ps4 right now really I think
so 20 I don't know I entered across and
he like market I don't know exactly
where he was looking I mean I had to
double-check that there was like a big
PlayStation sale yeah $20 like if it's
not when he's probably thirty I don't
know like yeah for this mode alone right
like it's just freaking cool man like I
can't recommend it enough
honestly cool yeah so that is available
on PC Xbox one ps4 all three platforms
like Rob is saying it's well worth
playing even if you might not have been
tied fall to before it's well worth
jumping back into and it's a good
supplement to the PvP if it's PvP stuff
which I've been playing pretty regularly
since it launched last October and
they're so yeah they're still updating
it seems like every month it almost like
some kind of update plus Papa's scorch
got a buff
papa scorch that was the funniest part
about the stream Jay I think some guy
like basically I would butcher it but he
basically did like the Giorno he turned
the DiGiorno motto into like pops chords
I don't know it's not see I've been
thinking that Papa Roach this I feel
like you need an ability or something
called last resort and there's gonna be
more up to Titans down there to like you
know they're really I'm pretty sure at
least one more which was then what was
the the melee based one that they saw in
the files just like that punches people
bison byeson yes because you know there
are three yeah there are you know three
chaste he's like they just did one the
kind of medium build with monarch like I
would expect two more and we haven't we
talked about this extensively throughout
the last year but the single-player
campaign is also like it's only like you
know I say only you can beat it in
probably four or five hours but it's
still well worth it especially at $20
now especially yeah I did like three
times yeah yeah you did a really good
video on how the Hard difficulty makes
that single-player like very different
not just harder cool yes thankful to
that's available on all platforms highly
encourage you to try it out Pete Brown
pyre you gave it a 9 out of 10 [ __ ]
you think the pyre is a superb game it's
superb out of 10 yes your reviews up on
games 5 I can go read that they probably
they can also watch it on youtube can go
watch it if you're on youtube right now
you liked it a lot from supergiant games
developers of Bastion and transistor and
Greg Kasavin used to be the EIC here at
GameSpot yeah I don't know if that's a
disclaimer or just a tangent but is make
sure that there's like no secrets about
our relationship and he's a writer and
designer yes yes so pyre is kind of I
think you did a good job in your view as
I mentioned but pyre is a difficult game
to describe even if you've seen gameplay
briefly yeah like what it is
structurally as a whole I know can you
sum it up I mean I had seen trailers
going into this review and I didn't know
what I was getting yeah but once I
started playing I realized okay this is
it's one part visual novel where you do
a lot of sort of relationship management
and decision-making as it you know comes
to socializing with your teammates and
even opponents and the other half of
this game is this what you're looking at
right now this sort of sport that
constitutes combat more or less but
really it's a it's a competition between
two teams who are fighting for the right
to send one of their team members out of
this purgatory that they're all stuck in
they're essentially all prisoners that
have been you know imprisoned for crimes
against the society the Commonwealth but
those things are usually unjust right
like you were sentenced for your ability
to read they don't want people to be
able to read in this world because you
know they're totally totalitarian
leaders and all that [ __ ] Fahrenheit
451 kind of thing yeah so really you are
sort of you're finding your way through
this world learning how to play this
sport getting to know your teammates
better and you ultimately work towards
this goal of sending enough people back
to stage a resistance back in the real
world and there are so many matches that
you can play there's a limited number
throughout the campaign and if you lose
them you can keep playing it's sort of
like a season of a sport right like you
play until the end and no matter how you
do that that's what you end up with but
if you don't win enough matches and you
don't send enough people back then the
mission you've been fighting for even if
you get to the end of the game will be
unsuccessful so you would have done
everything in vain so that's there's a
lot to talk about really the sport is
the most complicated part about it
mm-hmm
and I think where this game is going to
either click with people are not
depending on how they view this and how
much time they give it because it starts
off pretty easy and you're essentially
just trying to get a ball there's one
ball on the court at a time you're
trying to get any other team's goal and
you can do that in any number of ways
but you can only control one character
at a time and so how you sort of jockey
for position on the field you do that
based on the classes you're playing with
what their abilities are and through
scoring you know you might lose a player
for the next round like if I run it into
the goal that player is out who scored
for the next round but if I throw it in
then that means that player can come
back but throwing it in is very
difficult
and the distance that you throw it
dictates how many points you get so it's
it's this constant bouncing bouncing
active risk versus reward and the
respawn time for different characters is
also different yes but you can equip
different abilities and talismans on the
characters to sort of you know alter the
timing of certain things or you know how
things react based on like whether your
score or you're eliminated or etc etc
there's a whole lot to wrap your head
around here and it's also just a
gorgeous game to look at yeah it's super
pretty it sounds really good in almost
every regard like I love like the
characters don't really have voice overs
they have more emotes but they're all
very unique kind of gibberish yeah it's
definitely gibberish like the the
merchant guy I forget his name sits on
his dad's shoulders right yeah look you
can also turn I mean nothing you ever
would but you can if you click his face
you can like turn him on you can tell me
he's just like oh he does keep doing
that that actually bother me every minor
yes but yeah and like everyone's gonna
have a different experience and they
play through this game because you you
level up different characters or you
choose you know to retain different
characters to your playthrough or send
them back to the real world and as you
get to know them those decisions start
to feel a little bit more difficult to
make because well if you get rid of
someone like sure maybe you're doing
them a favor and you care about the
reason they want to be sent back but
then you're also taking away a key
player from your team mm-hmm and so then
from that point forward you have less of
a chance of success because you're
playing with characters that are maybe
weaker or you have less experience with
I absolutely love
I mean we're watching gameplay right now
and a few people were mentioning yeah it
does like I don't I think they might
have joined a little later saying oh
this looks like the people who made
Bastion yeah it's this in transition
transistor and Bastion all have the very
distinct supergiant style but they still
look different enough that you know
they're very they stand on their own and
this game you there's a musical tones
that also kind of allude back to Bastion
there's a lot of strings like guitars
and whatnot kind of this like funky feel
to it maybe that's not the right way no
no that that's fair but that's like some
of the tracks yeah right this game has a
incredible range of different types of
music in it and and it's always tied to
sort of the the
so that you're interacting with sort of
like theme music and it's it's also good
I mean we don't talk about polish and
game reviews because it's a concept that
is pretty nebulous like what does that
really mean but you know when I look at
higher I see like no rough edges like
nothing feels like it was you know under
realized or maybe it doesn't fit
everything seems to fit just right and
and feels so close to perfect in so many
ways yeah and it's the sport itself
they've invented by a kind of this
amalgamation of football basketball like
handball almost yeah I don't know how to
describe it's very much its own thing
but the way that they kind of fused the
RPG aspects of the characters with it
it's really fun I mean I just like
watching your game play you have far
more characters than I have at this
point I think I have six total yeah yeah
and getting more is really enticing both
in their characterization but also how
they affect the gameplay and then you
see here the maps start changing
yeah map centered feels like some
objects will move around as you bump
into them some are stationary and if you
there's a versus mode that you can jump
into where you can play as every
character that you will get through the
stories as well as every villain that
you would meet or even NPCs that never
even participate mm-hmm in these
competitions that are known as rights so
the versus mode is actually super robust
and the one disappointing thing about
this game or at least the one that is
actually worth spending time talking
about is the lack of online multiplayer
because it takes experience to really
understand the nuance to each character
and once you do you just want to put
that to the test on the end of the game
is tough like I struggled towards the
end that section was gonna ask you about
like the learning curve with regard to
the limited number of rights that you
can go through in the game because it's
like I feel like my biggest concern
would be that once I finally figured it
out I'm like super get this sport like
the game's over and I I mean like I
guess that enhances replayability in a
lot of ways because you have all these
interlocking parts and different
characters and a story that you want to
explore but that is something that I
would have wanted is like once you get
through the story and you feel like you
really have a grasp on this mechanically
like there's I mean there's local co-op
but yeah not everybody is gonna have
right right like if you just say hey
person who's never played this game
before let's let's have a match together
it's not it's stupid you just gonna you
know wipe the floor with that person
there are there are sort of like a way
that you can train and there is a way
you can train in the game it doesn't
feel as compelling like versus actually
just completing the story like spending
time doing that it's like I'd much
rather just continue playing but you
know the first half the game is super
easy and then like I was like you know
flawless record until I lost three
matches in a row and that's when I kind
of woke up and realized like I haven't
been really thinking about this game in
terms of everything it's presenting to
me and what options are at my disposal
and so then even with when you lose a
character that you're super familiar
with you have to start using characters
you're not there are general strategies
and concepts that are ingrained in you
throughout throughout those hours and it
becomes easier to pick up new characters
as you go so I think even if you just
spend a few hours with this game you'll
sort of realize like in general it's
good to do this and I should avoid doing
that right you know and then characters
will sort of just you know slightly
impact how you consider a match in that
way right to go back to the sports game
angle it's kind of weird that it
reminded me of rocket League how it made
sports games interesting to me again as
someone who grew up playing Madden but
kind of trailed off after I was like 14
or 15 or something but yeah the actual
learning that rules this game was like
half the fun but then it it is wrapped
in so many good narrative aspects and
just totally I love this game and the
story is telling but also yeah the music
the characterization and I know you have
like a favorite character Rob what was
his name
do you remember his name the ker Barker
one of those dog looking character laugh
out loud and like had to like put the
controller down it was such a great
intro and as Peter was commenting on
like the polish we're like it it really
very much is like a chord if you imagine
different like strings involved right
like art style timing with music when
this character or in characters for that
matter are introduced they punch in and
they have a line of dialogue that's so
unique basically that if I want to spoil
it too much but this character is well
should I yeah well there's there's not
much to spoil with the curse there
they're the they're the most
straightforward character they're like
small like dogs if you can imagine yeah
but
and this also ties in nicely to what I
was gonna get at that you mentioned
Peter with like basically this character
shows up and he's like such imagine a
small like Chihuahua with a studded
collar who's like let's go make your
blood boil
metal strings come in after just hearing
a very like in every ring full song
everyone else is like I need to go back
to the real world because my wife or
like there's injustice is I must correct
there like let's just freakin they don't
even want to go back they just want a
battle they love their life that's
choice it's so great and ization is
really good for it for every type of
personality and and also Titan is like
you know if you look at the gameplay you
are if you might be thinking like oh the
the the sport and the character dialogue
dialogues seem separate right but when
you're interacting with this guy he's so
threatening to a specific character that
you may have liked and we're using that
character in Britain many other
situations with right she's like I can't
this we have beef I'll tell you later
no way but like I know and then you
can't use them yeah that happens time
and time again we're it's not the same
right or the same style that you're
comfortable with you're always changing
up how characters little cheap in the
middle of a match they will cheat and do
something like I was about to win and
holy [ __ ] they just turned the tables on
me and where you maybe felt comfortable
for the last minute you're like crap
because I mean I think it's really
interesting combining a sports type game
with a visual novel like and from what
you guys have said it sounds really
successful but that's even cooler to me
the fact that it just ties in directly
in effects yeah you actually play that
sport it doesn't feel like they're
moving in parallel it feels like they
were they've harmonized in there yeah
but in sync it's a pretty bold move to
have a character that just throws the
rules out the window for a sport that
you have grasped the rules of but it
works it's not intimidating though like
it may appear that way but it's not like
once you as Peter said like maybe it
takes a loss it's very forgiving in the
beginning
yeah and lets you find your footing and
and that's also what happened to me
you mentioned like losing three times in
a row and you just kind of snap out of
it the other part about that is I think
it's very much like an RPG is when you
lose you lose and those outcomes are
your fault and it's pretty heavy
sometimes you're like well I want to go
back and replay that so I can win I want
to have that clean record and you can do
that they really you can but don't do
that
that totally defeats the purpose and the
game kind of addresses it in a way like
because there's this all-powerful entity
that like kind of speaks to you and it's
like whether or not you accept this is
up to you and you know Snape Kari yeah
oh no I just love that before every
match this just grand introduction with
like my hammer like pulling down from
the ceiling of an environment and is
yeah and at one point he's just like oh
your sorrow close to success and I want
you to lose but we must proceed anyway
so be it fail Nightwing's or whatever
your name is like yeah he was like I
initially I wanted you guys to lose but
I've changed my mind
it sounds like can you narrate my whole
playthrough damn dingo and the you
twitch chat Pete was asking if you have
an opinion on Bastion transistor or a
pyre for your favorite one the super guy
has done I tried to play Bastion many
times I didn't like it you know I have
not tried transistor gotcha I mean the
best the thing that I like most about
transition transistor was the music the
music's phenomenal making music is super
catchy here yeah and very different from
what you've described if pirate reminds
me a lot of what I liked about undertale
so I'm very very excited to actually
dive deep into this game like that
character relationships well just like
how the actual like the quote-unquote
gameplay portion isn't really like a
separate gameplay portion it's tied into
the narrative and that's InterPro vain'
throughout like that's my favorite thing
about undertale yeah it's it's all
elegantly connected again it again goes
back to the idea of polish like you
never I never felt like there was a
moment of transition
that felt just to facilitate a game you
know yeah cool
so pyre is out on ps4 and PC only I
think and then you can go read Pete's
review on GameSpot or watch it on
YouTube we have both covered on both
sides we also will be talking more about
pyre actually no nevermind we were just
looking to talk about pyre on a reboot
this weekend but we're not anymore
but you pretty much covered everything
stole your thunder yeah thank you cool
alright I'll talk about fortnight I
don't think you guys have gotten much
it's a chance to slant you play it once
a while I played a couple years ago I've
started yelling much more than where I
play it this is a really weird game to
talk about I was trying to describe
everything going on to you yesterday
Pete we have a freelancer reviewing it
I'm not reviewing it this is just my
thoughts on it but I do want to talk
about it because it's out in the open or
it's out in the wild if you pay money
for it that's a whole story yep so 2011
they announced this and Cliff Bleszinski
when he was still a epic at the Spike
Video Game Awards announced this three
weeks after they came up with the idea
and had an easy like a soft pitch so
this keep in mind Orcs Must Die came out
this year as call of duty modern warfare
3 did not have a zombies mode I'm trying
to set the stage for what this is and of
course minecraft was I mean minecraft is
always big but I think 2011 was like
minecraft was huge that was that was
when I was like reaching its peak
2010-2011 yeah it was at the top so this
game when they first announced it looked
like wave defense with minecraft aspects
that you build a fort and it kind of is
that but it also now that I've played
more of it it kind of isn't so yesterday
it did a soft launch you can pay like
full prices or a founder's pack price of
$90 to get a code and a ton of loot you
know go a hundred and you can pay
there's another one above that yeah 110
but their ultimate plan is to make this
free-to-play sometime next year I think
when they actually release it so exactly
it's an early access yes but you
wouldn't know that unless you looked in
the right places right so they have a
very big marketing problem with this
game and also the more I've played it
the more I have started to severely
dislike for tonight I love the idea of
I love a lot of things that they're
trying to do but right here you see
someone pulling out a pickaxe before the
wave defense starts it says defend the
van up there there's 45 seconds left
you're it's very much like Orcs Must Die
you're building these traps but you're
also in a third-person action game
centered around those traps but the more
I play there are so many things that are
at odds with each other and I was trying
to describe to you beat how it felt
almost like it's already designed to be
free to play but I waive full price one
thing I was missing in that conversation
was the idea that you can spend
real-world money to win in this game it
is already pay to win yeah so it's not
PvP so it's not right but you okay so
what you pay - sure - loot I don't know
but you're also but you are it's
supposed to be co-op but what this game
play right now is not really showing you
is that you're constantly competing with
your teammates for a lot of different
things so you first get into the match
the majority n - this instance it's like
destiny I don't know like bad comparison
- compared to a strike but you'll get
into this one procedurally generated map
and you'll all have these like main
quests that you have active like you
know like find five treasure chests or
find five of these tape recordings of
the person who uncovered the conspiracy
that led to this azam be out break but
at the same time you're also just doing
the same thing defending this storm
shield at your building or defending
this van this weather van that's trying
to land and so you could track the storm
a little easier it's a really
good-looking game I like the cartoon art
style but it's so cluttered as you can
see in this interface you have all three
characters their health you have your
health armor what's the bottom of
stamina then you have five different
resources and those are only like five
of the thirty five resources you can
think of you have four weapons at the
bottom and if you're not spending most
of the match beforehand breaking down
cars from metal you're not gonna have
enough supplies for ammo so you really
need to get into this game and know what
resource you're looking for and breaking
down cars but you're also competing
because it's shared loot so the first
person to get to a treasure chest it's
the only person that gets that time
there's one but you're also so yes
because at the end of a match you get
medals based on your combat score your
building score and those metals dictate
what level loot you'll get their loot
crate's and based on the metals you will
get a level three crate or a4 and it'll
upgrade the loot you're getting so
you're competing with other people to
get more kill
or build more or just you know like I
kind of contribute to the cause more
than they are even though it's kind of
purports to be a co-op game and I always
get kind of anxious if I'm like trying
to build and I see all three other
people at the zombie spawn point getting
all the kills I'm like well what is the
point of me doing this also together
yeah but you're getting build points
yeah but the build points don't really
matter because they're not necessarily
as useful especially because here's
another thing similar you have a bunch
of resources that go into like you'll
need like 20 nuts and bolts you'll need
20 wood you'll need 20 like specific
herbs to create this weapon but some of
those resources are always also go
toward upgrading your trap schematics
but traps are not nearly as useful
because if you upgrade your weapons you
don't necessarily need to build these
traps it's really fun to build these
cool-looking forts and kind of see what
people create but you don't need them
like so many are your resources going
toward weapons that but the same ones
could be going to our traps but there's
no point to upgrading your traps well
because your weapons are more useful
right I want if we if it brings up the
actual menu when we go back outside of
this this is in a match but I want to
show you these menus because I'm not
exaggerating 80% of my time in for
tonight is menus is in the menus not the
in-game inventory the menus I do before
we get there I want to point out that
the UI here is like a MOBA plus
minecraft plus an RPG I was like what is
that HUD know this I mean it's like one
of the most cluttered I've seen in like
modern gaming I mean a lot of like older
Japanese games have a lot going on right
but like this is a HUD that combines so
many different grabs of things and we
just talked about pyre like really
beautifully combining things that are at
odds
this seems that they just put a bunch of
different ideas together and then didn't
do the work to combine them yeah so I
don't know how to ET le e on Twitch is
telling me that you when you play with
friends you can share loot that still
does not change my opinion of the fact
that I'm competing with people for stuff
later on and the fact that I can
yeah you can and but most of time I
matchmaking with people but that's the
thing I've had to do so much research on
to what this game even is after I bought
it because I was excited for it's not at
all what I thought it would be but it's
also the fact that I can't I cannot
really stress how much loot you are
getting and how little of it matters
because you can break a lot of it down
you can put a lot of it into these
collections which is essentially a
scrapbook where it reminded me of pyre
where you kind of sacrifice this weapon
to be part of your collection and then
that'll give you these commander points
you're getting commander points which go
through the basic skill tree you're
getting research points which accrue on
a real world hour or like hourly 10
every 10 minutes or something and you
collect those you send people some of
your squads on expeditions and they'll
come back eight real-world hours later
with resources you're getting v bucks
you're getting founders bucks you're
getting daily rewards you're getting
quest rewards you are getting I don't
really know how to describe how
overwhelming it is how much loot I'm
getting and knowing that I'm only gonna
just keep upgrading these four weapons
and I'm gonna get ammo for these four
weapons okay and is weather balloons
sorry that's just part of it that's just
the character that you help out to track
the storm better the tone and the
writing this game is actually really
funny and whimsical and I think it
they'd nail it well what they're going
for but like you said Callie I think I
mentioned earlier that this game was
announced in 2011 this is very much and
it's been in development for six years
and they've been struggling you know
they did a soft another soft launch like
what two years ago 2015 they let people
play maybe was a beta maybe that's why
I'm thinking of but something they
released and you can tell this is very
much a product of like 2011 Sanskrit
Revelations came out and Assassin's
Creed was that at the peak of adding
more stuff just for the sake of it you
know like Call of Duty didn't have
zombies that year there was Orcs Must
Die which they were going for here
minecraft says peak this feels like an
amalgamation of so many different games
at that time but it doesn't do any of
those well and so many of it so many of
those things are at odds with each other
that I do have like fleeting moments of
fun in this game but so much of it is
dragged down by the fact that I feel
like this game is they looked at how can
we add more content for content sake to
this game because I feel like for a
while that's how we were judging games
you know like like I said ass ass creed
revelation
Assassin's Creed just continually gave
us stuff to do without any reason to do
it and there was no substance this feels
very much like a game that is designed
around the content like having more loot
and having more things to do without
actually having much reason to do it but
they didn't have a good foundation
before they added all that stuff and
maybe it's the result of six years in
development and they couldn't really
pivot and change completely on a dime
you've seen teams do that but it's
harder that's very hard to do and maybe
it's just so long development they lost
sight of what they wanted to do and
because so many new things have come and
gone in game design they were trying to
chase all these different things and now
they have it really feels like a mess
and I paid I feel like I was telling
Pete because of the research points you
have to wait real-world time for the
fact that you can pay for stuff to just
fly through and make the time spent not
as worthwhile I feel like I just paid
full price well more than full price
because I gave a code to a friend to
play with me I purposely got the $90 $80
Edition so I could give a code to
someone I just feel like I paid for a
game that's already designed to be free
apply when it finally launches and that
would be fine if I knew that's what I
was doing but I don't think their
messaging their marketing fully conveyed
that at all
so right now if you go to buy this game
on Xbox it is not in their preview
program it you buy it just like any
other finished game yeah it has a note
in the description of that product that
says early access season starts July
25th that is pulling a fast one on your
customers because that is not being
upfront and saying you are buying an
early access game you can't buy this on
Steam you can only buy this on Epic
Store on PC damn I mean they they are
skirting around the idea that hey this
we're not calling this game final mm-hmm
so what does that mean like what is left
to add and what are they gonna do what
are they gonna change I don't know how
to tell our audience hey here's the
reason why we're treating this like an
early access game here's what you can
expect when it's done who knows who
freaking knows and the way that they're
treating it right now like and if you go
to their page to buy it on their website
if you just google like bye fortnight it
takes you the page it says bye now
here's the pricing it doesn't say
anything about early access unless you
scroll like six pages down to like you
know look at all there
scrolling wallpapers with huge text
talking about the features and at the
bottom it says really access starts now
okay like Charlie Brown and spy Scout in
the twitch chat are correcting me
apparently you don't compete for chess
at the end
apparently you all get the same medals
which that's fine I don't care about the
chest I get loot that I'm never gonna
use I get loot that doesn't matter I get
loot that's just being thrown at me I
don't care about any of it it doesn't
it's not changing how I play I have four
weapons and I'm upgrading so even if I'm
not competing for these chests why do I
care about getting level three chests
why don't care about getting level four
why do I build why would I contribute
the resources to traps which don't
really do much when I can contribute to
the same four weapons I feel like this
game is just throwing stuff at me and
I'm playing to get stuff that I don't
care about like maybe maybe this is the
difference between where they are and
where they want to be when they get to
play exactly I'm I'm all for I love the
ideas game I love and I have no problem
with casual games you can just jump into
and play burst Diablo 3 is very
repetitive but I have the same character
I start in 2012 and I'm getting new
stuff that's making that character still
better five years later and I'm changing
how I play based on these weapons
nothing in fortnight is leads me to
believe that this game is I should have
paid this much money for it at all is
there like a risk reward with difficulty
like can you ramp up the difficulty or
some like that yeah so the game get a
letter once you get farther in like well
I mean there are specific you go to an
overworld map and you can pick different
like areas one will say recommended
power which is your base power
recommended power like five or six or
whatever I'm like 20 hours in at this
point and it gets difficult and it's
more fun when it's difficult but I just
pay full price for a game that I feel
like was preventing me from really
seeing the best it had to offer until
like 15 hours in I don't know and I'm
not like I'm sure this game is for a lot
of people I know like Aaron in our
office has been enjoying the casual
aspects of it the enjoying the building
and I do enjoy that but I don't think I
should have paid full price for the game
and this was like a thing didn't paragon
have a mixed messaging when you can buy
it but wasn't at all aesthetic stuff or
was that actually like abilities and
whatnot I'm not sure I remember when
that that happened and it was very
confusing to me as well we didn't end up
reviewing that game because it was like
it was like kind of first of this type
where it's not like it's early access
but it isn't and it's free-to-play but
it is
like thing that like normally I don't
think about price necessarily when I'm
thinking about what I get with a game
right like that's not how I evaluate
like especially if I'm writing a review
I'm not like oh this was $15 and I got
$15 worth of enjoyment but for in this
instance it feels like they're trying to
get out of a head of people who would
wait for free to play and be like it's
now available and then really really
bury the lead on it not being done and
right being an early access which feels
like they're just trying to cheat the
system it just that's the thing that
bothers me and that's why it feels like
why would I pay so much money for this
game when it's clear like from Mike from
everything you told me it's like
designed to be free-to-play yeah and
I've tried to get clarification from PR
about like so when this is deemed ready
for free-to-play that means it'll be
feature complete mm-hmm like well no I
mean depending on how the game goes
we'll keep making stuff for it and I'm
like well what's gonna change between
now and then oh well we're making new
stuff for it then what so then there's
no somewhat arbitrary point do you three
what point is it done when people stop
paying for this early access right I
realize that they do at what point is it
feature complete and then more content
is DLC that just enriches the experience
like the game tied right earlier with
like titanfall it's like you get a
complete game and they keep adding
things that make it better
versus this it's like oh we're just
gonna keep throwing stuff into it and
never finish it it's just I don't know
how that it's it's a weird murky area
but it feels unnecessarily complicated
yeah and it's not on Steam correct it's
not unseen it's not an ethics platform
because a steam steam game would have
that early access damn right yes cases
yeah I was ding shin like right yeah
yeah yeah so like I'm all for epic you
know figuring if a bunch of these gripes
that I have out and I know I'm not the
only one there was a huge reddit review
that blew up and the person got a lot of
critical feedback but I was actually
very fair and even without those
competition aspects if I did just truly
misunderstand those that's my fault but
so much this game as people in the chat
right now are saying tutorial doesn't
explain a lot of it there's so much loot
I have no idea what I'm doing with and
I'm spending the time to try to figure
this out I enjoy games that you have to
really dive into common chore it's
become a chore it's become it's
fruitless it sounds like yeah there's no
I don't I'm not having fun this game and
you can say that I just want to play it
casually which I do but there's there's
I can play a lot of other games calves
like like destiny casually I played
Diablo 3 casually I can play Minecraft
casual a to play Orcs Must Die if I want
to go back I can play all of the
different games inspired this game that
are all better than this games
individual parts yeah as of now and I'm
all for them changing my mind when it
becomes free-to-play and I'll pay for
more stuff there's I already paid for
there's something beside me you says are
really on like $90 hundred dollars
hundred well they're different they're
different versions yeah basic one is the
cheapest forty I think Keith's 40 I
don't know yeah let me look that up
actually um yeah but it's not
technically called early access really
it is when you get the game it finally
says early access like when you you
literally yeah but that aside the fact
that it's so complicated that somebody
who's actively trying to enjoy it like
Mike and like trying to put time into it
is misunderstanding elements of the game
and not through the fault of the game
it's not like you're stupid and you
don't get how this game works it sounds
like there's so much going on that it
it's so murky and unclear and it's like
that doesn't make it good like one of
the things I like about you know you've
mentioned destiny you can play casually
like destiny you can kind of scale to
your level of commitment to it so you
can play super hardcore and do [ __ ]
every Tuesday night and like have a you
know a regimen with it or you can just
jump in and shoot some cabal you know
like it's you can scale it to how you
want to play this is like if I want to
play it casually I still like the
tutorial isn't teach you how to do
anything I'm still gonna misunderstand
things I'm paid $80 to play a game
that's technically not finished it just
doesn't make any sense to me it's just
it seems like a huge cluster if yeah
yeah yeah Charlie Brown and Lee in the
twist yet thank you very much for
clarifying about the rewards and
everything because I had no idea or no I
thought I did and I still think you are
competing for chest and the Outlander
class is the only one they could see
through walls so why be anything but the
outliner class but in the end
even if I get that chest first what's
the point like like I again let me
clarify they're very good aspects this
game I think it's a gorgeous game I
think the ideas are there and I want
them to be turned around and I think
epic could because there's I mean
there's this period right now is great
for feedback and they have more money
now to fix these things so I want them
to it's also a good time to remind
people that we may have a different
opinion than the person reviewing the
game sure yeah okay so I'm not reviewing
it I just have a very different opinion
I might have a different opinion I don't
know I haven't talked to him it's just
this is how I feel I did this game is
not what I thought I'd be and part of
that ssam me but I think part of it is
also just mixed messaging on epics part
I hope this game Robin Callie talking
about it GameSpot Daniels review will be
Daniels review yeah yeah so yeah there
are a few different tiers there's a $60
there's like an $80 there's a hundred
ten it's just different starter packs I
mean really quickly because I you kind
of did just wrap this up but it does it
remind you of no man's sky and that like
what you're getting is not what you
expected but also what you're getting is
not like no man's sky I know Peter you
had you didn't think that it was a bad
game it was just people had really high
expectations right we talked about this
before with this game it sounds like you
expected one thing and then also what
you got wasn't even yeah up to par is
that like is that a fair year son yeah I
think I just yeah I think I thought it
was something it wasn't personally right
and I know a lot of people like I said
there's people in the chat right now
that are saying yeah it's it's just fun
it's a casual fun night and I agree I
could I could casually have fun this
game if it'll I would happily play this
game if it was free to play and not
spend any money and just like but my
time isn't even being rewarded with good
rewards in-game rewards I think it's
just design around this constant stream
of content that doesn't matter and to
clarify standard ition is $40 but I'm
not done deluxe edition is $60 Super
Deluxe Edition is $90 guess how much the
limited edition is it's not one time
$150
oh I'm gonna tell you what it gets you
though cuz this is important I don't
mean to like one exclusive legendary oh
it's a very carful colorful I know it
looks really good rare starter Hero pack
of eight heroes rare starter weapon pack
for weapons and one trap exclusive
founders pistol to exclusive exclusive
and game defenders to digital standard
editions for friends exclusive founders
chat channel and more details below but
so many of those things those heroes I
don't feel like they matter I don't feel
like I feel like I'm gonna put them in a
collection and it's gonna give me one
point to increase my fortitude which is
like and this is all this generalization
these are like fortitude resilience
increasing your base health increasing
your character health but why would I
put this toward ammo and I could just
put this toward why would I put this
toward to trap when I could put it
toward a weapon that it's gonna push me
through the whole game then things get
difficult 20 hours in and it becomes
much more fun which everybody tells me
and I and from the amount of people that
are telling me that it gets more fun 20
hours and 15 hours and I don't I don't
doubt that I believe all of you but I
just paid full price for a game that
doesn't that doesn't seem like it
matters until 15 hours in and also it
doesn't respect your time there's so
many fantastic games out this year that
like a lot of us haven't gotten to like
I still haven't played near the way I
like I actually want to like finish that
game right like I I'd rather play a game
that respects my time more so than what
it sounds like this game is doing
because if it's not rewarding you for
what you're doing then well the best
free-to-play games
I think fine I don't love I don't like
the free-to-play model but you know like
the whole idea is you can either spend
time or money and the best for you play
games I think find a way to make your
time worth it like plants vs. zombies -
I still play it every once in a while
and that the same thing like you could
pay for more stuff but I don't because I
feel like the game actually rewards me
for the time I put into it that's a very
I think I'm my head's in the
tower-defense realm right now but again
Charlie Brown and the toys yeah thank
you so much for clarifying and Charlie
Brown said there's an edition in game
that you can only buy in game guess how
much that is and if you bought this he
or she bought this on ps4 it's $250 that
you can access after you buy the stand
I'm actually not sure so I don't it says
it's in game store but ok there's these
if you have all these people are
enjoying it I'm really happy because
epic of course has worked for what six
years in this game and so we should help
them out and make sure that they group
all their money
but no but nobody but turn policy yeah
but no I'm probably not
there's too many layers there's too much
going on I myself maybe just if I
couldn't find a better third person
tower defense game in Orcs Must Die or a
better building game with with whose
creations are not ephemeral keep in mind
a lot of these creations will disappear
after that round where in minecraft is
permanent on that server as long as you
don't destroy it or something doesn't
happen in that server I can play destiny
for the social aspect of catching up
with a few friends five friends from
doing a raid if I want to do that I
could play Diablo if I wanted a
repetitive Luke grind that actually
rewarded me for my time and keeps
changing how I play it but I just don't
feel like any of those ideas are
congealed well enough in this game to
make any of my time worth it right now
and if it was free-to-play maybe I
wouldn't maybe if I didn't again I paid
for it and that's on me
I spent money I chose to spend money on
it I'm happy to hear that people are
enjoying it like I like it when people
might like things and I I always want
people to have a good time yeah no III I
your problem rustled right now this
could be very fun for a lot of people
and I do not I'm not like I can
understand that and it's not like
completely foreign to me why people have
fun of this I just said men when does it
go free-to-play don't know sometime in
2018 yeah but again thank you to
everybody the twitch and YouTube chats
are joining in on that conversation you
were helping me out a lot I appreciate
it because there's so much this game I
still don't understand but I do still
have the same opinion of it based on
some huge fundamental flaws I find with
it but it's just not for me
but again we'll have our review from
someone totally separate who may have a
different opinion than me sometime in
the coming future future sometime in
2018 when our review free to play you
can read it it's been categorizing this
game as early access or not has been a
very confusing process and I'm not
getting answers that that are satisfying
me and that's unfortunate yeah anyway
cool that's for tonight uh yeah that's
also our show thank you everybody for
joining I do have a giveaway it's me you
get a date with Pete Brown no not a date
like the rest of your life ah you get
permanent marriage I don't know don't
tie me down
leave our Twitter the person who runs
our Twitter
she will if she didn't already go to
GameSpot on Twitter follow it the
account retweet the tweet about the
giveaway we have 5000 gigantic codes the
biggest comes you've ever seen 35
numbers yeah so there you go if you're
in the twitch chat Khaleesi play is that
a Shiva she just tweeted the giveaway
Thank You Shiva and if you're in the
YouTube chat just again just go to
Twitter if you don't follow us follow us
retweet that's week later on the week we
will pick a bunch of people to give this
code to this game recently like finally
released yeah it kind of came out and
had a I think a free period what
happened to like a disc it's such a we
were just like lauding titanfall 2 and
overwatch and the division for being
really good games that are platforms
that revolve and I love that and I love
when games do it right I don't like when
games do it wrong through it weird yeah
what we'll also have a review of
gigantic coming up so cool glass stuff
coming on GameSpot so yeah I will pick
winners for those codes later on we have
5000 codes I was good I was considering
like saying ten to make it seem more
exclusive but there's five thousand and
you'll probably get one I can't promise
anything I'm digging myself a hole cool
everybody thank you for joining this
week as always I don't even know 5000
people they are dead yeah hey Richard
Lee gently except in the back Shiva for
doing our Twitter account everything
Ryan uber who's in our YouTube chat and
always moderating every week thank you
for all your help
behind the scenes everybody in the chat
again thank you for joining on this
conversation this week I had a really
good time we'll be back next week I'll
be out for a couple weeks like late
August September but you have to deal
with me for another few weeks
cool but as always we'll see you next
Wednesday and thanks for stopping by
[Music]